- And that's why we use Clean and Go.
Because it's fast and it works.
- You can say that again.
Now, come here and give
your husband a kiss.
- Cut.
Ronnie, let's just stick to the script.
- Oh, no improv?
- No improv.
- All right, just the words
on the script, gotcha.
- [Director] Here we go.
- And that's why we use Clean and Go.
Because it's fast and it works.
- You can say that again.
- Whoa, cut, cut.
Ronnie, can I talk to you for a second?
- [Ronnie] Yeah, yeah.
- I think that's going really well.
- What's going on?
- What, I said the words
that were on the script.
- What's with the kiss?
- You don't like the kiss?
- It's not in the script Ronnie.
- I know, I just thought
it was an artistic choice.
- Are you trying to kiss her?
- No, no, it's--
- No, it's Greg, my
character wants to kiss her
cause that's his wife.
I'm trying to show that
we're a married couple.
- Why don't you do this?
Simple hug over the shoulder, all right?
One arm over the shoulder.
- Yeah, I could do that.
- And that's why we use Clean and Go.
Because it's fast and it works.
- You can say that again.
- [Director] Cut!
- I feel like you can
really see the passion
in that last one.
- Very passionate, too passionate.
- Back story is that's Carol.
I met her when I was 16 years old
and I fell in love with her.
We've been married for six years.
She's a lawyer and I'm
about to get the reigns
to my dad's car wash, all right?
Right now, money's not that great
but all we have is our love.
- Okay, you know that's cute
but this is your back story.
You're trapped in a loveless
marriage and that's my vision.
- And that's why we use Clean and Go.
Because it's fast and it works.
- What are we doing Carol?
- We're using Clean and Go honey.
- No, what are we doing?
(sad music)
- We're just going through the motion.
- Exactly, why?
- [Carol] Because people change Greg.
- Not us, we were suppose to be different.
- We were suppose to but
then you started drinking.
- You're gonna bring
up the drinking thing.
- [Carol] Yeah, because
I can't forget about it.
- That was two months ago.
I'm a change man.
- How do I know that
person won't come back?
- God, you know what,
I'm gonna do something.
I'm gonna promise you.
I'm gonna promise whenever you talk to me,
I'm gonna look you dead in the eyes.
I promise whenever you
have a bad day at work,
I'm gonna come home with
cookie dough and flowers
and I promise, I promise
to you I'm gonna love
you like we're 16 again.
- Greg, I love you so much.
- I love you so much.
Now, let's make love right here
and rekindle the fire.
- [Director] Cut.
- What?
- I thought that one was pretty good.
- I thought it was great.
Are we good here?
(upbeat music)
- It's here.
- [All] It's here.
(group murmurs)
- I think they got it, get it.
- Yeah, you get it.
- It's here.